there is a breakthrough in a feud that
has been intensifying between Egypt
Ethiopia and Sudan the dispute is around
a giant hydroelectric dam now Ethiopia
is building on the now River close to
the border with Sudan as you will see on
our map now Egypt gets most of its water
supply from the Nile it's worried that
its share of the water will be reduced
Winnie Thea Pia starts to fill the mess
of death now discussions between the
countries broke down earlier this year
and Egypt's president Fattah el-sisi
asked u.s. President Donald Trump to
mediate delegations from Egypt Ethiopia
and Sudan met in Washington they also
met with Trump
they set a January 15 target for
resolving the issues but even if they
come to agreement Egypt still faces
broader water problems that have left
its farmers struggling it's as if
someone has turned off the tap water
from the River Nile used to flow
abundantly through this canal irrigating
the farmland here in those in Egypt now
the kernel has dried up forcing Hamid at
the rebel to abandon half of his plot
there is very little water from the Nile
sometimes there's a bit more in winter
mainly because the land doesn't need so
much water then but in summer we don't
get any water Egypt's government wants
its farmer to irrigate more efficiently
and to plant seeds that required less
water it's also trying to recycle water
but the measures simply aren t enough
throughout Egypt the drastic rise in
temperatures and the increase in the
intensity of climate events such as heat
waves increases the amount of water that
crops use so the amount of water that
used to be enough for a certain plot of
land 20 or 30 years ago is not enough
today we need more water
no Ethiopia is building a giant dam
upstream on the Nile many fear Egypt's
creeping water crisis could get worse
it's European ground relay system is set
to become Africa
largest hydroelectric power plant once
the reservoir starts to feel Egyptian
official worried the water levels will
fall even more it's about same for Mia
when more it must be more than 90
percent of egypt's water depends on Nile
water outside our borders as such
projects like dams which are being
established in the source countries
without consultation with the countries
that the Nile pours in to represent a
problem even small changes to the Niles
water flows will have a big effect if
the Nile water drops like I said before
any two percent drop of water affects 1
million people so it's really the more
impoverished categories and the farmers
I think that will be affected most Egypt
Ethiopia are continuing the negotiations
of a de Nile's water and hope to reach
an agreement early next year